[Música]
y
gran audición para la obra del fin de
año del colegio
la canción preparada pensada yo estaba
listo un solo cambio
la profesora no estaba sola yo no podía
cantar enfrente más personas que no sea
la maestra que hago que hago bueno me
arriesgo quería conseguir un papel
y empecé a cantar primeras dos estrofas
sin ningún problema
pero cuando se estrelló y tuve que subir
el tono
me patina la voz y me que hemos
congelado
no puedo seguir
yo creía que tenía mucha confianza pero
como diría tussam todo puede fallar
como definimos auto-confianza
auto-confianza desconocimiento poder
defender tus ideas tus convicciones
creen en el juicio propio todas bilidad
tu poder todo lo que necesitas para
sobrepasar los nervios frustraciones
estrés
y seguir adelante
recordó una vez estaba con unos amigos
jugando al fútbol en lo cual no era nada
bueno
y yo trabajando y ya me habían metido
dos goles muy vagos
cuando uno de mis compañeros iba a sacar
de la mitad de la cancha escucho que le
dice a otro que este no ataja una
con decisión fui y lg no querés atajar
voz
sanz lo que me respondió
me dijo que iba a atajar peor que yo
después oí el arco y atrás del resto del
partido
también nos juega bien al fútbol pero
confío en mí mismo esa confianza me dio
libertad yo pude decir lo que pensaba
sin la necesidad de vida mi compañero
puedo expresar mis ideas y fui libre de
cometer errores expresar nuestras
propias ideas defenderlas y mantenerlas
es muy importante y sería imposible si
no contáramos con auto-confianza
pero no siempre está presente
es un trabajo diario y constante con uno
mismo donde la presión externa siempre
nos empuja para otro lado qué pasaría si
cada acción que tomamos en el día nos
hiciera cuestionar nuestras habilidades
dudaríamos nos realizaríamos podríamos
hasta aparecer mismos estatuas no
haríamos nada
o simplemente copiaremos lo que hace el
vecino muchas veces no muy convencidos
de querer hacerlo decidí jugar a hockey
el año pasado subí de categoría y con
eso llegó un gran cambio pasé de jugar
de una cancha de 7 jugadores a una
cancha de 11 jugadores hace ya dos años
había empezado a jugar al hockey y yo
creía que tenía mucha experiencia pero
la cancha nueva y el equipo nuevo
hicieron que min iba en mi primer
partido no sabía ni dónde pararme en la
cancha la auto confianza disminuye este
estrés y permite a la persona seguir
adelante y pasar increíbles y
satisfactorios momentos pero a dónde va
esto cada uno es libre de mostrarse al
mundo tal y como es como alguien único
con algo único para contribuir entonces
cómo conseguimos auto-confianza primero
hay que convertir lo negativo a positivo
hay que empezar a darse cuenta de esos
momentos en que la negatividad nos
bloquea y tratar de reformular los de
otra manera tratar de pasar las frases
como no seré capaz de hacer esto se van
a reír de mí no soy lo suficientemente
bueno a frases como soy lo
suficientemente capaz y lo voy a hacer
puedo lograrlo volviendo al hockey a mí
primero con el 7a
los contrarios había contraatacado y
teníamos una jugada muy peligrosa en
nuestra área un compañero le pegó a la
ocha que salió disparada hacia el
lateral derecho de la cancha donde otro
compañero la recibió viendo que estaba
solo con tres defensores adelante decidí
correr hacia el área contraria para
darle apoyo y cuando me paso la bocha y
yo estaba solo en frente del arco todo
se congeló
en ese momento no creí que iba a meter
el gol
pero escuchaba como la gente afuera
gritaba vamos juanchi
y p
col
en ese momento había cambiado mi
desconfianza por confianza y había
desempatado el partido la adoptó
confianza también se basa en la
percepción de nuestros logros para
poderlos aplicar en otras áreas en las
que nos vemos un poco más inseguros como
les dije antes
son jugar hockey y después de meter ese
gol
mejore mucho
y metimos goles que no hubiera podido
meter si no me hubiera conocido a mí
como un jugador
recuerdan cuando les dije que no jugaba
bien al fútbol
hace poco me di cuenta que el hockey era
igual al fútbol mismas tácticas y
posiciones con equipos número de
jugadores
porque no trasladaron partido de hockey
a un partido de fútbol así mejorando mi
técnico con los pies por fin aprendí a
jugar al fútbol para conseguir
auto-confianza una persona tiene que
creer que puede
la mejora personal es un trabajo del día
a día y déjenme decirles una última cosa
antes de irme ante una situación difícil
seamos un poco mismos vayamos despacio
congelemos ese instante y confiemos
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]